so wanted to do a video in palpitations
it's a very common thing someone sitting
there and all of a sudden the heart
skips or they get this sudden extra
pounding of the heart or elevated heart
rate and they're like what's going on
with my heart it can be pretty scary but
palpitations are a problem with the
rhythm of the heart and what controls
the rhythm are electrolytes okay that
would be like potassium magnesium sodium
and calcium so palpitations really are a
deficiency of these electrolytes so
either you're not consuming enough
vegetables for example to get your
electrolytes or you're not absorbing
these electrolytes and there's usually
two reasons for that
one is you have insulin resistance now
again you've probably seen this in other
videos the key to open up the cellular
door
it's called insulin okay one of the
purposes of insulin is to help you
absorb minerals into the cell insulin
resistance is a situation where it
doesn't connect and it doesn't open the
door so you become deficient in these
minerals so insulin resistance is a
common cause for heart palpitations
because you're not absorbing these
electrolytes so even one of the symptoms
of diabetes is palpitations simply
because of the insulin resistance and
the blocking of absorption of these
electrolytes
now one more cause and that would be low
stomach acids because it takes certain
acids to absorb the minerals and that's
why if you even look up in Merck's
manual for example one of the medical
books of one of the side effects from
people with acid reflux and GERD is
palpitations why because you don't have
the pH the acidity to absorb these
electrolytes which control the rhythm
alright thanks for watching hey if
you're interested in finding out the
underlying cause of your body issues
click the link below and take the
evaluation quiz